why do black holes look like this first
of all you're not looking at the black
hole itself you're looking at something
called an accretion disk that's the
stuff falling into the black hole
orbiting as it goes but why does it look
all wonky Optics you know Saturn right
it's got all those beautiful Rings those
Rings go all the way around the planet
we just can't usually see the back
because Saturn is in the way well it's
the same for black holes that accretion
disc goes all the way around but black
holes bend the paths of light so they
can distort images the front part of the
accretion disk looks as expected this
part up here is actually the back of the
disc if we fly around the black hole you
can get a better view of the distortion
foreign